Under our feet,
there is an unseen world
more diverse than all
the tropical rainforests combined.
Teeming with microbial life
and critters, large and small,
this hidden world of soil
is on every single continent.
But most of us know little to nothing
about this vast world under our feet.
And for most of my life,
I was no exception.
I grew up [a] very curious
and adventurous kid.
I spent a lot of time climbing trees
and falling out of them.
And I spent a lot of time
getting really dirty.
In college, I had to take a class
for a science requirement,
and I was shocked to discover
that being really curious
and loving dirt could be
a legitimate career.
So it took no convincing whatsoever
for me to change my major,
and that's how I became an ecologist.
In graduate school, I studied
how the loss of a seed disperser,
in this case, the winnow ant,
affected the plants that they disperse.
In my research site,
we were discovering that these ants
were moving up in elevation
to escape a rapidly changing climate.
But they were leaving the plants
they dispersed behind.
So while I came
to grad school to study ants,
I all of a sudden found myself
studying climate change.
And because ants nest in soils,
I had to learn a lot more about soil.
What I couldn't have predicted,
as that young, curious, budding ecologist,
was that I would spend
the next decade of my life
thinking about the invisible
army of soil microbes
and how we can harness
their awesome powers
to help address climate change.
But before we get to all of that,
let's start at the beginning.
Soils are considered to be
the skin of the Earth.
They're only a few meters thick,
but they support all agriculture
and every single terrestrial biome.
Soils help protect our food supply,
clean our water, boost our immune systems,
and they serve as a source
for some critical medicines,
including many that have
yet to be discovered.
Without Earth's exceedingly
thin layer of soil
and its multitude of organisms,
we would not eat,
and humanity as we know it may not exist.
And soils, like many good things,
they take time to develop.
They form over hundreds
to thousands of years
as rocks break down
and plants and animals decompose.
As soils form, they accumulate
and store carbon.
In fact, there are billions of tons
of carbon stored underground.
Two to three times more
than what we have in the atmosphere.
Plants and soil work in collaboration
to drive the single most important
transformation of carbon on this planet,
photosynthesis.
Plants take carbon dioxide from the air,
and they combine it with water
and sunshine to create sugars.
And of course, to grow plants.
Plants and their sugars eventually
decompose in the soil,
feeding the microbes.
In fact, most of the carbon
that comes in through plants
ends up in soil at some point.
The carbon cycle continues.
Microbes and their carbon
eventually break down,
and the carbon from the microbes
sticks to soil particles,
creating what we call
soil clumps or aggregates.
Because microbial carbon is sticky.
So when that microbial carbon
ends up in a clump,
it's physically protected
from further decomposition.
And what we know now
is that the majority of soil carbon
that is sequestered
is actually dead microbes
or what we call microbial necromass.
That necromass can stick around in soils
for decades to millennia,
especially if we leave soils undisturbed.
But over the last 12,000 years,
we have lost billions of tons
of carbon from our soil
as humans converted
grasslands and forests
into agricultural fields and range lands,
building roads and cities.
One of the major drivers
of that loss was the plow,
which, at the time, was a major
technological breakthrough
that really revolutionized agriculture
and altered the trajectory
of human history.
With each pass of the plow,
those plant roots and soil aggregates
that we know are really important
are broken apart,
exposing carbon to decomposition.
Today we use more than a third of our land
to feed and clothe
billions of people on this planet.
But we're losing our soils
at an alarming rate,
and with it, we're losing their fertility.
Without that soil,
it's going to be a lot harder to feed
what is going to be
close to 10 billion people
on this planet by 2050.
That's going to put a lot more pressure
on what is already a disappearing
and resoundingly
underappreciated resource.
There is no machine
that can bring soil back.
No technology that can do what thousands
of years of rock weathering
and biological activity have achieved.
But we can build our soils
and put more carbon underground
with a little help
from plants and microbes.
Rebuilding soil is going to require us
to fundamentally rethink our reliance
on technology and chemicals
to deliver what soils can do on their own:
support life.
And life in soil is mostly microbial.
The Dutch scientist,
Antoni van Leeuwenhoek,
saw tiny organisms
he called the "wee beasties,"
under his microscope about 350 years ago.
And with the rapid innovation of molecular
and computational tools,
we are finally getting
a sneak peek at who they are
and how they make their way in the world.
Here's the thing.
A teaspoon of soil
holds billions of organisms,
things like bacteria, fungi,
protists and archaea.
These microbes
are the movers and shakers
of nature's carbon cycle.
They drive really important
processes in soil,
they take organic matter
and convert it into complex
carbon molecules.
And having more carbon in soil
is transformative.
As carbon accumulates,
agricultural fields can hold on
to more water and more nutrients,
building resilience that helps them
deal with the ups and downs
of a changing climate.
That resilience means
plants can grow more consistently,
even when the weather is fickle.
And the awesome thing is
carbon-rich soils help buffer us
against what is an uncertain
climate future.
The trick is to really rethink
how we do agriculture.
So there is the good news,
which is there are some
tried and true ways
that we can get more carbon
in our soils and build our soils back.
We can plow less,
and we can make sure that we have
roots in the ground year round,
feeding the microbes
and powering that microbial engine
humming under our feet.
And we can do this.
The other thing is,
diversity is the key
ingredient in this recipe.
Diverse plant communities
support diverse microbial communities
that can transform and store more carbon.
Diversity is good for soils,
and it's good for climate mitigation.
Just like we need every microbe,
we need every farmer and rancher,
every climate solution and every solver.
So ...
Healthy, carbon-rich soils
matter today more than ever.
The other great thing
about carbon-rich soils
is they help farmers have
more consistent agricultural operations
and more sustainable ones
that can withstand the ups and downs
of a changing climate.
That's a huge win
for the people that grow our food,
it’s a win for climate,
and it’s a win for us consumers.
So how do we do it?
Well, there are three simple
things we can do.
Number one, we have to protect our soils
and the carbon they already hold.
Number two, we can get
more carbon underground
by growing diverse, climate-adapted crops.
And number three, we can let
the microbes do their thing.
Leave them alone
by leaving the soil undisturbed.
It sounds simple,
and that's because it kind of is.
But there are some questions
that are left to be answered,
and there's a lot of room
for us to innovate.
We need to track and measure
our climate progress.
We need to develop more
climate-resilient crop varieties
that can grow deeper roots
and pump carbon underground deeper.
And we need to rethink
our economic models and agriculture
and help support and incentivize
these carbon-sequestering
agricultural practices.
So lots of room for innovation,
lots of room for research.
Good news for us scientists.
But we don't have time to waste.
Climate change is here and it's affecting
all of us, whether we know it or not.
It's affecting every single ecosystem,
including agriculture.
Soils are the literal foundation
of life on this planet,
the reason that we can eat
and the climate solution
just waiting to be unlocked.
So let's build back our soils,
help our planet by looking
down to the ground.
Thank you.
(Applause)